PAUL RUDD
And for the rest of you kids out there,
a word of advice...
Oh, hello.
Didn't see you there.
Hi. I'm Paul Rudd. You might
know me as Scott Lang a.k.a. Ant-Man.
Now, Scott is many things.
Former convict, a dad, an Avenger...
But he's also a best-selling author.
And now you can purchase my... "his" very
real book: Look Out for the Little Guy!
That's right. This once movie prop is now
an actual real-life book you can purchase
wherever books are sold.
How's that for meta?
In this new book I'm almost certain was
not written by me, we pull back the
curtain and uncover the man behind
Ant-Man, Scott Lang. Who is he?
What's he like?
Why does he look so much like me?
It's a tale as old as time that's
so good it practically reads itself.
A publication similar to but
not the New York Times calls it...
So, if you're like me and you've only ever
read the back covers of books to
say you've read them, do
yourself a favor and pick up a copy of
Look Out for the Little Guy!
It'll change your life.
Can I say that? No?
It might change your life.